This ellipse would be centered at negative 2 negative 3 would have an a value
of 4 and a, b value of 2. Great work if you found all 3. For the center we take
the opposite signs of what's next the x and the y in the parenthesis. Ellipse
so for x we'll have negative 2 for the x coordinate at the center and negative
3 for the y coordinate of the center. Remember this really shifts an ellipse
centered at the origin two units left and then three units down. So, this is
how we know our center is here. Next we take the square root of 16, which is
our a value. Remember a squared is always underneath the x squared term for
ellipses. And to find b, we take the square root of the denominator of the y
term. So, the square root of 4 equals 2. From our center we can move four units
left and right to get these two points on our ellipse. And from our center we
can move two units up and down to get two additional points on our ellipse. And
if we look closely at the points that are vertically aligned with the center,
we can see that one point is two units above the center and another point is
two units below the center.